today, a decree was signed that
establishes the rules for trading
Russian natural gas with the so
-called unfriendly
states; we offer contractors
from such countries a clear and transparent
scheme to purchase Russian
natural gas; they must open
ruble accounts in Russian banks.
starting tomorrow, from April 1,
if such payments are not
made, we will consider this a
default on the part of
buyers with all the ensuing
consequences,
no one sells us anything for free and
we are also not going to do
charity work, that is, existing
contracts will be stopped in a situation
where financial  the system of Western countries is
used as a weapon when companies
from these countries refuse
to fulfill contracts with Russian
banks, enterprises, individuals,
when assets in dollars and euros are
frozen, use the currencies of these
countries it makes no sense
to continue so naturally, especially since in the
case of further gas supplies and their
payment in the traditional scheme, new
financial receipts in euros or
dollars can also be blocked. The
risks of the current state of affairs
are, of course,
unacceptable for us  then the
period of payment for the supply of Russian
gas for Russian rubles is an important step
towards strengthening our financial and
economic sovereignty,
we comply and will continue to comply with
obligations under all contracts,
including gas contract, we will continue to
supply gas in the established volumes, which
I want to emphasize in the established
volumes and  at prices determined in
existing long-term contracts,
these prices are several times lower many times
lower than current quotes on the spot market,
however, judging by the statements of individual
politicians, they are ready to neglect the
interests of their citizens just to
please their overseas owner,
users understand that the United States  they
will again try to solve their problems, it is
their problems at someone else’s expense, including
launching a new wave of emissions and budget
deficits, it has already grown exorbitantly and the
leading European economies are breaking
records by an iota of hair removal
in the United States, and at the same time they are trying to dump their
mistakes in economic policy
they are always looking for blame for us,
added that the United States will still try
and capitalize on the current global
instability, as they did forward the
first and second world wars during
their aggression against Yugoslavia and Iraq
, etc. for Europe, this means
large-scale industrialization and the loss of
millions of jobs in  Against the backdrop of rising
food prices, gasoline,
electricity, housing and communal
services, and also a drastic decline in the
standard of living of citizens
, this is the price that the ruling Western leaders
offer to pay people, as I already
said, for their ambitions and
short-sighted actions both in
politics and in the economy, including for
economic war  cat  they are trying to
unleash against Russia,
or maybe they have already unleashed